飛ばさないと 感情と集中力
感情に支配されるとはと人は他のことに興味を持てない
感情と集中力っていうのは結構相性がいいんですね
感情が決めたことを揺らぐこと
うん ちょっと文章が間違ってますね
まあ感情が決めたことは揺るがないんですね
感情で決めちゃうと もうはっきりするんです
優柔不断にはなりません
感情と理性は正反対なので
感情によって活発になることは一概に良いとはないんです
で 感情っていうのは 例えば何か欲しくなっちゃうと
頭そればっかしなんです
あの人のことを好きやと思っちゃうと
もう他が見えなくなっちゃうんです
そこでもうずっともうまっすぐらに行くんです
怒りの場合も同じことで
怒ってしまえば 嫌になったらもう他いくら言ってももう頭には入りません
だから入った対象から抜けないっていうことが集中力なんです
ただ あの人のことは大嫌いだと思ってしまえば
周りが何言っても聞こえないんです
嫌いで一筋でいくんです
だから簡単に集中力売れますよ
感情で欲とか怒りとか出しちゃえば
しかし 感情っていうのは理性の反対なんです
バカっていうことなんです
完全に だから集中力欲しいんだからでて
感情で作ってはあかんです
とても良くないんです
中身が良い感情であっても理性がないので安全と言えないんです
例えば欲 怒りは憎しみとかね
嫉妬の感情っていうのは悪いのは決まっているでしょうに
では良い感情ならいかがでしょうかと
文学作品を作ったり 音楽を作ったりとか
良い感情でしょ？いい作品作ろうではないかと
しかし 感情と理性がないんですよ
だから良い感情にしたっても
気をつけろと 理性がないんだから
先天的感情 はい また先天的なことに戻らなくちゃいけないんです
生命には 生命に先天的にある感情とは貪瞋痴です
どんな生命にも先天的に感情が密接ついてあるんです
それは貪瞋痴というんですね
欲と怒りと無知 これが心の煩悩で不幸を司ってるんですよ
だから どんな人であろうとも
どんな生命であろうとも
一を放っておけば不幸になるようになっているんです
それはもう自然法則です
別に神様とかなんだらかんだらじゃないんです
この自然法則やと非科学的に物事を見る人には発見できないんだから
もうありともしない物語を作るんですね
神様方が最初に作った人間が神を裏切ったと
その罪は我々受けなくちゃいけないんだと
いかに非科学的かというと
人間は猿から進化したっていうことの方があんまり強烈な考え方なんですけど
まあ信じますよ 人間が
それはこの 21 世紀で
だからこのそれがなくて
人間には心を調べてみると
どんな生命にも貪瞋痴があるんです
この貪瞋痴っていう感情が放っておけば堕落するという不幸になる
これは当たり前でしょうに
ウイルスに感染したら病気になると決まっているんです
ウイルスに感染すればするほど健康になるというのはありえないんです
単純な論理って？論理じゃなくて因果法則なんです
自分だけではなく 他人にも害を与えるんですよ
その感情で だから貪瞋痴の感情で集中力を作ったらどうなるのかというと
人は不幸になる 周りにもすごい迷惑を与えたり
害を与えたりする これ例なんですね
貪欲の衝動で必死になる人も
怒り 憎しみ 恨みで必死になる人も
無知で他人に言われるから
他人もやってるから必死になる人も少なくありません
この世の中でだいたいみんな必死ですよ
集中力は結構あります
貪欲か怒りかなんです
嫉妬か憎しみか恨みかで
それで必死で頑張っているんです
結構集中力ですけど それからみんなやってるんだから
これ無知 そういう人々はたくさんいるんです
世間がこの状態に集中力だと言うんです
だから世間でいう集中力はそんな程度なんです
あんまりいいことじゃないんです
活発は活発です 時々恋する人のことを思い思い出して
夜も寝ないで徹夜するとかね
寝られないとか これはごく普通
結構な集中力なんです
本で負けてこれを読んでくださいって言ったらすぐ寝るんだから
感情的集中力の問題 基本的には感情は悪なので
短期的な良い結果があっても
長期的には悪結果になるんです
これは大きな問題ですよ
例えば 怒ってすぐ相手をぶん殴ったら
相手が引っ込むかもしれませんよ
ああ いい結果出ましたね
しかし 長期的に見るとまずいんですよ
金が欲しいんだからね
大金欲しいんだから 銀行強盗したことと同じなんです
確かに銀行強盗が成功したらむっちゃ大金手に入るんです
よかったよかったと 短期的にはいいんです
それからなんです 問題は
しかし 私たちはこの短期的な結果だけ見て
欲で怒りで無知で生きてますよ
銀行 銀行強盗の例を見ればわかるのに
で 理性が機能しないので
道が違っても調整できない
それで感情で生きていると調整できない
これちょっとまずいんだから
こっちやめましょうとかね
だから夫婦の間でも言ってはいけない言葉を言ったりとかね
付き合っている時でも言ってはいけないことそれ言ったりして
やってはいけないことそれやったりとかね
いろいろトラブルが起こるでしょうに
その時理性が機能しなくなっちゃいますね
感情が上がったり下がったりするので
一定の力持てない 持ってないんですね
持てない 集中力も上がったり下がったりですね
感情っていうのは激しい波
上がったり下がったり
上がったら集中力があって
なくなっちゃうともうないと
時々勉強する時はライバル意識で
もうあいつにもあいつにもあいつには負けたくはないんだとかね
この怒りが出てくると
ずっと勉強するんですけど
怒りってもう下がるんですよ
そうすると まあいいや
嫌になっちゃったと またやめるんです
そういうわけで この感情が引き起こす集中力っていうのは
上がったり下がったりなんです
集中力は結果が出る まで保つという保証はないんです
で また問題あります 感情で頑張っても
簡単に他の感情に置き換えてしまうんですね
欲で頑張っても怒りになったりしますよ
強い感情は弱い感情を置き換える
強い感情とはより悪い感情ということです
例えば もういい人間に良い人間になろうと勉強すると
それは欲の感情なんですね
時々何か気に入らなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると怒りが出てくるんです
怒りの方が良い人間になろうということは抑えてしまうんです
それでもうやめますといきなりやめちゃうんです
よくあるでしょ 嫌になったとかね
もう嫌になった もうやめましたとかね
良いことをなのにやめてるんで
だから別な感情が置き換えるんですよ
だから感情の置き換える場合は
悪い感情はなんですね
より悪い感情に置き換えてしまうんです
ですから 感情中心的な人はさらに不幸に陥る
さらに悪いことをしてしまう可能性が大きいんです
感情に起こる集中力には
感情にではない まあ感情でかな
仏教は集中力という言葉さえも使わないんです
本当は仏教は使わないんで
この感情で必死になっていることに集中力と言わないんです
言葉 本当は機能同じなんですよ
私もそれすごく疑問に思ったんですよ
このアビダンマ心理学なんか見ると
同じ機能なのになんで同じ単語使わないのかと
やっぱり仏教は心理学というより道徳はもう無視しません
だから一体だからね やっぱりそこは言葉使わない方がよろしいと
使ってないんです はい
それから邪定というんですね
いわゆる間違っている集中力
ミッチャーサマーディ
経典ではミッチャーサマーディという言葉があります
あの集中力っていうのはサマーディなんです
仏典では使ってないんです
間違っている集中力にはサマーディって言わないんですが
お釈迦様は 1箇所に 1箇所ぐらいあります
2  3箇所ぐらいあります
ミッチャーサマーディという言葉を使ったところは
正しくない 不幸になる
悪行為になる集中力を意味します
だからミッチャーサマーディっていうのは
邪定っていうのは正しくない
不幸になる集中力のことなんです
宗教の世界で行うマインドコントロール行為は一つの例です
宗教ならマインドコントロール
それっていうのはミッチャーサマーディ
悪 邪定なんですね 集中力が気分がいいんです
だから宗教に入って気分が悪くなるということはだいたいないんです
気持ちいいんです 結局マインドコントロールされてるんですけど
気持ち悪いとは言いきれ言いませんね
苦行 宗教的な儀式などを長く実践すると病みつきになることもあります
それも邪定なんです 例えば
長い間苦行するとすごいサディスティック心理なんですけど
病みつきになっちゃうんですね
やめられなくなるんです
それやると 苦行やるとすごい気分がいいんですね
この気分がいいということは集中力なんです
それから儀式でもね 私はいくらもう馬鹿にしたってもね
やる人はやるんです 今まで長くやっていたんだから
気分がいいんです 大太鼓叩きながら
ものすごくうるさい音を立てながらね
何か呪文を唱えたりすると気分がいいんですよ
だからやめられないんですね
何もやられませんだけど
まあ世間に私ほど馬鹿がいませんよとか言ってるだけの話なんですけど
例えばチベットの人々はね
何か何か回してますよ
回しながら人と喧嘩するわ
もういろいろ買い物をするわ
これ高いでしょうとか何とか言ったり
でもその間もこれ回ってるんです
だからなんであれでオームマニパドメフムというマントラが入ってるんです
観音の呪文 あれ一回回ったらものすごい徳が積むんですよ
だからこんなあれ 無駄ごとよくやりそうあんたと言いながらも回ってるんです
だから宗教ってそんなもんなんです
そこでいろいろお寺でこのいろいろ歯車がセットしてあって
一つこうやってオームマニパドメフムを回しちゃうと
たくさん一緒に回るんです
自分が回すのは一つだけなんですけど
それに歯車でついてついてついてついてあって
全部回るんだからね もし車が 100台あったら一回で 100回なんですよ
呪文が もう天国を新しく設立しないと天国もないと思いますよ
だから調べたら作ってないんですよ
古い経典である天国以外
誰も作ってないんで 作ればいいのにね
昔そんなことやらなかったんだから
こういう天国に行ったんで
今はこれよりもう何億倍も徳を積んでるんだから
かなりすごい天国があるんだぞとかね
作っちゃえばいいのに
良い感情 はい 次に別な良い感情に入りましょう
不貪不瞋不痴と説かれているので
悪感情をなくすことです
お釈迦様はいきなり不貪不瞋不痴と言うので
貪瞋痴に対して ということは
悪感情をなくせばいいっていうことなんです
肯定的に的な語を使うと
献身的 貢献的 献身的 無執着は不貪なんですね
慈しみ 哀れみ 差別感をなくすことは不瞋なんですね
理性を育てること 真理を発見することは不痴
智慧です だから 否定的に肯定的にもどちらでも言えるんです
これって良い感情なんですね
本当は感情という言葉使えないんです
献身的にいることって感情ですかね
貢献する気持ちが感情じゃないでしょ
もっと冷静でクールで理性なんです
はい 一応覚えておきましょう
制限なく育てられます
これが制限なく育てられます
良い感情は 悪感情をさらに強化して集中力を高めることは破壊的な行為です
例えば戦争とかテロ行為とかね
悪感情をどんどん強化するでしょうに
どこまででも強化できませんよ
例えばテロリストを育てる場合は
テロリストにどんどんどんどんいろんなことを知っていって
マインドコントロールをして
して あの怒りがどんどん高ぶっていくと
テロ行為に行く前に本人が死ぬんです
できなくなって自壊するんです
まあ言いたいのは この悪い悪感情で集中力を育てると怒りで潰してやるぞ
例えば北朝鮮で毎日朝晩やってるでしょ
怒りで怒りでもう戦ってやるんですよ
我々こそ世界一強いやと
アメリカなんかもう何のこともないんだとかね
みんなそう思ってるんです
本当に 何のこともないんだと
もうちょっと吹いたらもうアメリカ倒れると思ってるんです
だからまあそんなことをやると自分が破壊するだけ
だから悪の感情で集中力はちょこっと育てられます
それからできないんです
しかし 良い感情ならいくらでも成長します
じゃあびっくりぐらい早く飛ばします
人は感情 破壊に陥るのは構わないのですが
他人に多大な害を与えるんですね
だから 悪感情は良くないんです
しかし 良い感情には理性が欠かせないので
制限なく育てられます
理性があるんだから 制限なく育てられます
自分にも他人にも幸福を与える行為です
良い感情というのは 自分にも他人にも幸福を与える素晴らしいことなんです
はい